in general because as we put it above
substance is in itself or implicitly
subject all content is its own
reflection into itself the substance or
substance of anything that exists is its
self-identity for a failure of
self-identity would be its dissolution
self-identity however is pure
abstraction but this is thinking when I
say quality I am saying simple
determining this it is by quality that
one existence is tutor is distinguished
from another or is an existence it is
for itself or it subsist through this
simple oneness with itself but it is
thereby essentially a thought
comprehended in this is the fact that
eating is thought and this is the source
of that insight which usually eludes the
usual superficial talk about the
identity of thought and being now since
the substance subsistence of an existent
thing is a self identity or pure
abstraction it is the abstraction of
itself from itself or it is itself it's
lack of self identity and its
dissolution its own inwardness and
withdrawal into itself it's own becoming
because this is the nature of what is
and insofar as what is has the nature as
this nature for our knowing this knowing
is not an activity that deals with the
content of something alien is not a
reflection into itself away from the
content science is not that idealism
which replaced the dogmatism of
assertion with a dogmatism of assurance
or a dogmatism of self certainty on the
contrary
since our knowing sees the content
returned into its own inwardness its
activity is totally absorbed in the
content for it is the imminent self of
the content
yet it has at the same time returned
into itself for it is pure self-identity
and other necessities the cunning which
while seeming to abstain from activity
looks on and watches how determinate
nests with its concrete life just where
it fancies it is pursuing its own
self-preservation and particular
interest is in fact doing the very
opposite is an activity that results in
its own dissolution and makes itself a
moment of the whole
here in Section 54 Hegel is going to
Center the discussion around something
that has been working in the background
the entire time at which he hasn't
explicitly formulated and that has to do
with the identity of thought and being
and so this is a good point to pause and
talk a little bit about this term
idealism oftentimes when we're using it
in ordinary English today we don't mean
by it what is meant by it in philosophy
what we tend to mean is that a person
has ideas and then they think that you
know those ideas can be realized in the
world or that the world a lot to conform
to their ideas usually there are you
know happy shiny ideas we talk about
somebody being idealistic most often in
contexts where we think that their views
on things or actually I would have line
with what a more realistic that's the
opposite that we we bring up a more
realistic attitude or perspective one
that takes into account the dark corners
the you know hidden motives all the
things that make life such a mess so
there is something there's a connection
there between that sort of notion of
idealism
and what Hegel is proposing for us in
the phenomenology and you know in some
respects you could actually see what he
talks about as big riff flows translated
here as as superficial literally lacking
the concept attitudes towards the
identity of thought and being you you
could say if you wanted to that in order
to be a German idealist all you really
had to do was to assert the identity of
thought and being there are idealists
who are who are not German who are
influenced by you know particularly
Hegel II like Royce in America or you
know the British a galleons like like
Greene and Bradley
but what Hegel is is they actually
targeting here
is mistaken and therefore superficial
understandings of the interrelation
between thought and being now to be an
idealist means to say not that
everything is all in your head but
rather that everything that we can
encounter everything that we can
experience everything that we can apply
our minds to and conceptualize is
already in some way thought that doesn't
mean that it's our thought because we're
not you know the center of the universe
but it doesn't mean that it is
intelligible it's a world that in
certain ways becomes humanized you might
say or at least rationalized made
accessible to us and this is going to
carry him through the entire way so he
reminds us at the beginning this is
stuff that we've already gotten over in
general substances itself or implicitly
subject because of that all content is
its own reflection into itself so
there's this dynamic that we've just
talked about in the last section so now
he says the subsistence or substance of
anything that exists so anything that we
can encounter anything that actually
exists that has reality the substance of
it is self-identity a thing is what it
is and it's it's kind of interesting we
will often want to invoke the law of
identity a equals a can't do an awful
lot with that as it turns out in
philosophy but people love to talk about
it Hegel is gonna use this to sort of
open things up a bit
because yes you're right the you know
for something to be for it to continue
in being and he has to remain that same
thing otherwise it's not it's not itself
being all right if I suddenly turn into
a butterfly all you would really see at
this point is you know dr. sailors there
and then poof there's a butterfly and
you could say well I think the
butterflies him probably has his
consciousness or maybe it starts talking
the way they do encourage
movies or something like that in that
case we're saying that there is a
self-identity and that the you know the
transition between one shape and the
other doesn't really matter what matters
then is say consciousness something has
to count as self-identity now Hegel says
this is also pure abstraction and this
is going to be the dialectical linchpin
around which things are going to turn in
this he says self-identity is pure
abstraction but that is thinking
abstraction requires a thinker to be
carrying it out it's going to sound as
if there's thinking also going on in the
thing and we'll get to that in a moment
so then he says when I say quality I'm
saying simple determinant it is by
quality of one existence is
distinguished from another or is an
existence to be something is to be
something determinate and to be not that
to be not that not that so already in
positivity there's a certain kind of
negativity for me to be what I am is for
me not to be you or not to be that
camera or not to be this chalkboard some
of those are more relevant to my being
at this given point in time there's also
a mode of negativity that's going to
come up more intimately related to the
existing things and it's going to come
out of the very fact of abstraction
itself
so he says comprehended in this is the
fact that being is the lot this is the
source we talked about evolve a the you
know insight that usually lose a
superficial talk about identity thought
being now since the subsistence of an
existent thing is self identity or pure
abstraction it is the abstraction from
itself this is an important juncture so
I want to I want to go back over that
again for a thing to be what it is
means that it has something that we can
actually point to as the abstraction of
that that thing that's its identity and
yet at the same time for any given
concrete thing the abstraction is also
in a certain way not the thing it's a
negation of the thing it's stripping
away things that we might say that well
that's just accidental that's not really
the essence but those matter to Hegel so
that leads us over here back to self
uttering a thing becoming other than
what it is as we engage in the process
of looking at it as we pay attention to
it as we are engaged with it so he says
it is the abstraction of itself from
itself or it is itself it's lack of self
identity so to possess self identity
leads us into at the same time lacking
self identity these two go together this
is one of those places where you know
somebody I can't get it I can't
understand how that can be a thing
cannot be and not be at the same time
they wanted to both the law of
non-contradiction you could think about
it this way Hegel is not saying this at
this point but you could think about it
this way the law of non-contradiction
itself is subject to itself and is other
than itself that's one of the things
that's that's sort of going on in the
background here in Hegelian logic so he
says and I'm inserting this ore into
here as well he talks about these as
sort of as if they're the same and I
think that's actually a mistake on Halos
part the thing can either fall into
dissolution which is what a lack of
self-identity is or it can offer to us
into itself a kind of inverness he talks
about a turning inward and this is the
process of becoming so it's really not
just the identity of thought and being
that he's talking about the but the
identity of thought being and because
being in becoming being intimately
related to each other as we're seeing
here all of this is being thought by
some subject in a trivial sense that's
true cuz a little over we're talking
about right here your subject diamond
subject Hegel's the subject the book is
leading us through this but he means
something deeper so he says this is the
nature of what is and insofar as what is
has this nature for our knowing this
knowing is not an activity that deals
with the content of something alien is
not a reflection into itself away from
the content science is not that idealism
so he's targeting other kinds of
idealism which replaced the dogmatism of
assertion with the dogmatism of
assurance or a dogmatism of self
certainty science is not going to be a
dogmatism at all if it's going to take
this in in the mere fact that something
is thought for us that it is a content
for our consciousness doesn't mean that
we're entirely in charge that's one of
the differences between Hegel and some
of the other idealistic thinkers that
he's sort of trying to get beyond we
have to give ourselves over like you
said in previous sections to the object
learn from it what it he has to teach us
it's not alien to us but we're not it's
masters so he says on the contrary are
knowing sees the content returned into
its own inwardness we have to follow
into the inwardness of the thing it's
activity is totally absorbed in the
content what does the imminent self of
the content yet it has at the same time
returned to itself for its pure
self-identity in other notes that s'what
this is depicting pure self-identity and
other nests and it's up to us to
actually penetrate into that to follow
along into that to
knock on the door so to speak and you
know try to sneak in through through a
open window you might say so it says
thus it's the cutting which seeming to
abstain from activity looks on and
watches how to terminus with its
concrete life all of this has been
trying to get us back to concrete
existence she's going to have you know
talk about a lot of metaphysics in this
but the metaphysics has to inform our
actual experience of things this is what
could be going on when we're
experiencing he says so he says just
word fancies that is pursuing its own
self-preservation a particular interest
in fact it's doing the very opposite
it's an activity that results in its own
dissolution and makes itself part of a
whole part of the whole this solution is
not always just disappearing altogether
when we're losing ourselves in this kind
of study we are actually embracing the
this systematic whole halo would say
above we indicated the significance of
the understanding in reference to the
self-consciousness of substance we can
now see clearly from what has been said
its significance in reference to the
determination of substance as being
existences quality self identical
determinate Nisour determinate
simplicity determinate thought this is
the understanding of existence that is
the nature of existence from the
standpoint of the understanding
hence it is noose as an exhaust
recognized the essence of things to be
those who came after him grasped the
nature of existence more definitely as a
dose or idea determinate universality
species or kind it might seem as if the
term species are kind is too commonplace
to inadequate for ideas such as the
beautiful the holy and the eternal that
are currently now in fashion but as a
matter of fact idea expresses neither
more nor less than species are kind but
nowadays an expression which exactly
designates a notion is often spurned in
favor of one which if only because it is
a foreign extraction shrouds the notion
in a fraud and hence sounds more
edifying precisely because existence is
defined as species it is a simple
thought noose salt simplicity is
substance on account of its simplicity
or self-identity it appears fixed and
enduring but this self-identity is no
less negativity therefore it's fixed
existence passes over into its
dissolution the determinant no seems at
first to be due entirely to the fact
that it is related to an other and its
movement seems imposed upon it by an
alien power but having its other nacelle
and being self moving is just what is
involved in the simplicity of thinking
itself for this simple thinking is the
self moving and soft differentiating
thought it is its own inwardness it is
the pure notion thus common
understanding to is a becoming and as
this becoming it is
reasonableness
so how does the human understanding
which is one of our faculties grasp
being as it's been articulated
throughout the rest of the the preface
in this Hegelian way is the
understanding actually up to the test
here Hegel is actually talking about
some of his predecessors ideas and he's
suggesting to us look what I'm talking
about is not something that was
explicitly set by by these previous
great thinkers but it's what was going
on in the background that enabled them
to make the advance that they they did
at a time so what can he actually tell
us about this he starts out with saying
we've just talked about the relationship
between existence and quality and we're
gonna we're gonna talk a bit more in
further sections about the importance of
quality by the way if you look at
higgles logic you'll see that that
quality is one of the you know sort of
key ideas in our understanding of a
thing not quantity we've talked about
why mathematical cognition doesn't
provide us with the model but but
quality you know it's a metaphysical
principle that we want to come to
understand and this is essentially
Aristotelian Aristotle devoted a lot of
work in his in his metaphysics and also
in the other works that kind of
accompanied it like the categories to
thinking in terms of what actually is a
quality can we distinguish different
types how do they work in any case he
says this is determinate nastain an
existence is determinate self-identity
simplicity and now how is it grasped
well you know the understanding grasps
at the subject the mind is getting a
hold of it so he says we can now see
clearly that existence is quality self
identical determinant ness or
determinate simplicity
terminal thought this is the
understanding the thing that's you know
out there let's take things that are out
there before we start thinking about you
know what about my emotional states or
parts of myself or my own thoughts
because then it gets a little bit more
more tricky but a thing that's out there
is also for us it's in our consciousness
we are aware of it we are connected with
it if not it wouldn't you wouldn't we
couldn't even say that it exists we
could imagine it out there of course but
imagination is not the same thing as as
reality as we all know so he says this
is understanding of existence
hence it is he uses this Greek term here
news as annex an Icarus suggested now
having sagres you know he's a little
he's less than clear I'm not gonna say
he's a little unclear he's it goes
beyond that he's less than clear in part
because we don't have that much of what
he actually wrote so we have to
speculate and our speculations are based
in significant part on what later
thinkers made of his doctrine and they
may have been faithful to it in me may
not have that's not particularly
important here what is important is that
Hegel is picking up on this notion that
mind permeates the entirety of not just
the universe by existence so mind is
literally everywhere in everything and
you know going on now the question is
that is that our mind no we're not we're
not at that point yet this is an
advanced Hegel thanks to realize this so
he says it's nooses an examiner's first
recognize the essence of things to be
those who came after him grasped the
nature of existence more definitely and
now we have two other
as a dose or idea and where are these
these notions coming from these are
coming from Plato so you know we have a
thing as being something that that is a
marker or expression or imitation when
have you an idea or of the the form is
how we often translate a dose and
there's you know a whole bunch of
discussion but what does Plato mean by
form and all that here's enough for it
for this point
Hegel is saying there's some advance
payment first we have an ins a Gris then
we're having Plato Plato is of course
going to locate the forms somewhere else
there there apprehensible by us through
our mind there in the thing in a certain
way but that's very murky how they're in
it more by sort of reflection or
participation then becomes a longing
Aristotle and now we get terms or
concepts like universal kind species
Aristotle does continue to use the the
word a dose but now he means this sort
of thing which is found the Masters do
right which is found in the thing this
piece of chalk is a determinate thing
it's being used up because we're doing
this it's if we might not even get all
Hegelian about that is approaching
dissolution it is becoming not identical
with itself because it's you know all up
here and this is something different
than this this conveys intelligibility
is widespread you know we can say well
it's still the same substance no it's
not actually it's become something quite
different but Aristotle would say this
you can
again in a number of different ways you
can look at it as chalk as having a
certain essence you can look at it in
terms of its shape it is a thing like
this it can also be looked at in terms
of its functionality there's a writing
instrument right in conjunction with the
blackboard or I suppose a sidewalk
somewhere that is closer to treating the
thing as the thing as it is for the
understanding then Plato was or an exam
is was so there's a progress that's been
been made here and Hegel says you know a
lot of people want to go back to
something more like like Plato's idea
they say that the term species are kind
is too commonplace it's to inadequate
stupid Estrin we might say it's too too
low for ideas such as the beautiful the
holy the eternal we you know we want
those to be ideas rather than species
are kind but if we want to develop
understanding of those things it's an
advance actually to think of them in a
more mundane way higgles not going to be
saying aristotle had it all right we're
gonna stick with the categories and the
logic that he has he's dude he's
proposing something very different but
what he is saying that Aristotle did get
right was saying that if we want to see
the the beautiful or the eternal it's
gotta be where we can actually encounter
that doesn't mean that an SP you know
something that we can see smell touch
you know feel like as if the eternal is
a hamburger we can consume you know and
then digest but what he is saying is
that this way of looking at it is
actually going to lead us in the right
track so he says idea expresses neither
more nor less than species are kind
Chris Denise is precisely because
existence is defined as a species
it is simple thought
newse simplicity is substance and so on
account of its simplicity or
self-identity it appears fixed and
enduring but this is an illusion
these things that were encountering
particularly when we thought of them in
terms of universals they are not
actually so enduring the you know self
same throughout all of time that they
don't engage in a process of developing
like he says the determine the
self-identity is no less negativity
therefore it's fixed existence passes
over into its dissolution the
determinant Ness seems at first to be in
due entirely to the fact that it's
related to an other yeah there's there's
you know two very important kinds of
negation that are always going on within
the Hegelian dialectic there's the
negative relation to something that's
not yet something that's other and then
there's the negative relation to
something that is not it but actually is
it with that came out of it we've seen
that things self-other and that are
reappropriation into themselves and
these two can interface that's part of
why things can actually interact with
each other within the Hegelian universe
you might say also why we can come to
have conceptions of them why we can
think about them why our thinking itself
can be productive it's due to the power
of like he said the power of the
negative that were able to do this so he
says having its other Nisswa thin itself
and being self moving is just what is
involved in the simplicity of thinking
itself for this simple thinking is the
self moving in self differentiating
thought it is its own inwardness it is
the pure now he brings up his term
translated as notions or our concept the
German for it
yes that's what a thing really is is its
concept its but Grif all these other
things are sort of steps on the way
towards grasping that but this is what
we're we really want to get to and he
says the common understanding - is it
becoming and as it's becoming it is
reasonableness
so what's translated there in that last
sentence first and he says its first and
elite meaning that it's it's it's
understandable
it is comprehensible it's it's
intelligible we could say and this
intelligibility once we start thinking
in terms of the notion this
intelligibility doesn't quite get us to
turn you on which is reason but it does
get us on the way to pronounce the kite
reasonability rationality the property
of being something that goes beyond just
the Faculty of the understanding to
something that thinks in terms and and
works things out in terms of the concept
the notion